[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to episode 187
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Jon, and I am here
with my colleague, Mark.
Hey, Mark, how's it going?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hey, Jon, how are you?
JON FOUST: I'm
doing pretty good.
Got stung by a bee for
the first time in my life.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh no.
What happened?
JON FOUST: As soon as I
walked outside, it was like,
you've never been stung by bee?
Let's check that off the list.
[DING]
Right on the ear.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You know, I
get the feeling that's probably
not on most people's
bucket lists,
but maybe that's a great thing.
You can now put it on there
and then check it off,
and say, look, it happened.
I may as well take
credit for it.
JON FOUST: Right.
I survived the heat wave that
just passed through New York.
So it was pretty, pretty
hot, but luckily I
do pretty good in the heat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
it's brutal weather lately,
with the exception
of, of course,
San Francisco, which is
pretty generally 68 and sunny.
JON FOUST: Right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I'd
feel very fortunate to live
in San Francisco.
Obviously, hopefully everyone
does well with the weather
out there.
But if not, come
to San Francisco.
JON FOUST: I might have to
come out there and spend
a couple of weeks out there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We can get
some rematches for our "Smash
Brothers" game too.
JON FOUST: Definitely.
So in this episode, we're
going to sit down with Adé from
Instruct, along with Sandeep
from Google about what Instruct
does, and the awesome arcade
machines that came out at Next.
Those were really,
really fun to play with.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
we saw huge crowds
standing around the developer
zone and kind of playing around
with-- well, a bunch of
old school arcade machines.
So if you want to hear more
about what those machines were
and what Instruct
does, then definitely
stay tuned for the main content.
JON FOUST: And
we're going to get
into our question of
the week, which is--
I kind of want to get more
familiar with Google Cloud.
How do I really navigate
the space for material,
and what kind of
offerings really will
help me ramp up really quickly?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, there's so many,
and I've heard this question
a number of times recently.
So happy to dive into and share
a few more details on that.
All right, well,
first, let's move on
to actually talking about
our cool things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: So the
first thing that
came to my mind that
was pretty interesting
was there was a project
called Byteboard
that came out of Area 120, which
is Google's experimental lab.
And what it is, it's a
structured, identity blind
evaluation process
platform for interviewing
that allows managers to
reliably trust recommendations,
and candidates get to
work through interviews
at their own pace
without the stress
of going through high
pressure theoretical tests.
So none of those
questions like how many
golf balls fit inside
of a school bus,
or things like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Design
10 uses for a manhole cover
in the apocalypse.
It was always stuff
like that got me,
and it was like, this is a
really interesting interview.
I'm not sure if I understand
what they're going for,
but I'll try.
JON FOUST: My personal
favorite is the egg dropping.
I love that question.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, the egg dropping.
JON FOUST: Yeah, yeah, so you
get to drop an egg, I think,
once or twice, and
you to figure out
what's the highest floor you can
drop the egg without breaking
or something like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
I don't know that one.
But I'm sure there's no
shortage of all those kind
of horizontal thinking
questions that
were very, very interesting
to look at for the interview
process.
JON FOUST: Right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, away
from that, one of the things
that came across my table quite
a few times in the past week
has been this
Gartner announcement
that Google Cloud is a leader in
the infrastructure as a service
magic quadrant space.
Now, for most
people, it probably
doesn't mean a lot to
them, because it's not
going to change
what you're doing
or change what's out
there on Google Cloud.
But I think it's a
really cool recognition
that Google is doing
some very, very
fun things in the infrastructure
as a service space.
But if you look
at the blog post,
you can see some
other customers that
are taking advantage of cool
things that Google are doing.
And hopefully that's kind
of some inspiration for you
to look at, all these
different services
that are out there, all these
different tools, and saying,
well hey, what can
I build with that?
JON FOUST: I think that
a lot of our developers
who are just getting into
this space, when you get
recognized kind of like
this, it helps build almost
like a reputation for us.
So I'm pretty excited
to actually be
named a leader in that space.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
JON FOUST: So the next
cool thing to come out
is bike shares becoming
pretty, pretty big
in a lot of major cities.
And Google has actually been
able to share real time bike
share information
using Google Maps.
So there are roughly around
1,600 bike share systems,
and almost 18 million shared
bikes in urban cities.
So since it's so
mainstream now, imagine
being able to use Google
Maps to find locations,
exactly where to find bikes,
when they're available,
and the bell curve
that you usually
see when you see how busy
a certain station is going
to be with bikes.
So it's pretty
awesome to see that.
And I'm actually
thinking about picking up
bike sharing and stop driving
around the city, which
is kind of funny when people
find out that I actually
have a car in New York City.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, that
is not a very common thing.
Nobody drives.
There's too much traffic, right?
[DRUMS]
[CYMBALS]
JON FOUST: [CHUCKLES]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Classic.
Well, the last cool thing I have
for the week is that we have
this cool little Medium post
that one of our customers
engineers put out, who was
able to show that you're able
to take the Cloud Shell, which
is that environment that gets
spun up with your Google
Cloud account that you can go
into and do some
semi-persistent stuff--
well you can go ahead and run
Visual Studio Code in there,
which is an IDE that I
think a lot of people
have been talking about
in the past year or two
as a really cool IDE that has
a lot of features into it.
Well, you can just kind
of run that directly
from your Cloud
Shell environment.
So you go in there, you download
code server and set it up,
and now you have a web IDE
that is Visual Studio Code.
So this is a really,
really cool way
to offload the IDE and code
aspect from your computer
onto the cloud.
So a lot of thanks to Christian
Hes for putting up this blog
post that shows how easy it is.
JON FOUST: That's
awesome, especially
with some systems
that don't allow you
to install Visual Studio Code--
I'm not sure if Chromebooks
actually run Visual Studio
Code-- but if you can
install Visual Studio
Code on a Chromebook, whether
you're using Linux or not,
it'd be awesome just to do
it in Google Cloud Shell.
So definitely a great blog post,
and thanks for the information.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, very, very
cool to be portable and have
that power wherever you go.
JON FOUST: Well,
that was awesome.
Great chatting with you.
Now let's talk with Sandeep
and Adé and see what they have
to talk to us about
these arcade machines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
All righty, then.
Thank you so much for
joining us, Adé and Sandeep.
First things first, Adé, why
don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself, and who
you are, and what you do.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Sure.
My name is Adé Mochtar.
I'm CTO and co-founder
of Instruct,
and Instruct is a learning
platform for technology.
JON FOUST: Can you
go a little in-depth
as to exactly the type of
things Instruct teaches?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
So what we believe at
Instruct is that learning
is done best by doing.
So especially in technology,
things change so fast,
and you need to keep up.
And the quickest way
to learn new technology
is actually just play with it.
And that's exactly what
Instruct offers you.
So what we are able
to do with Instruct,
we are able to spin up
training environments,
sandboxes, and give
people challenges
to solve using technology.
And in that process, we
validate that what they're doing
is correct, and guide
them in the right way
in the right direction
if they get stuck.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Can you maybe give
us a little example
of the type of courses you
might find on Instruct?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
We have a bunch of
courses on Kubernetes,
of course, where you get a
running Kubernetes class there,
and we ask you to deploy
stuff, to fix stuff,
to configure stuff.
But also, we have
quite a lot of content
on the HashiCorp ecosystem
console, their forum, or stuff
like that.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
And I will be trying to take
one of your Kubernates courses,
because I need to
brush up very fast.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: [CHUCKLES] Cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's like
a digital classroom, right?
People can kind of come
in, they can study a topic,
and then they can put
their practice to the test
by actually running the stuff
in an actual environment, right?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
So what we do is we give
people some flashcards
with some information,
and then we drop you right
in the sandbox.
You have to get your
hands dirty by actually
using the technology.
JON FOUST: And I like that
term you used earlier.
You kind of start
playing around with it.
The reason I think
that's super accurate
is because at Google Cloud Next
2019, if anybody was there,
first of all, it was
awesome, come back next year.
But second of all, there were
a bunch of arcade cabinets
that were also involved
in this process.
And Sandeep, you were kind of
involved in organizing this.
Tell us a little bit more about
what the arcade cabinets have
to do with Instruct.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, sure.
So funnily enough, I
was in Hamburg, Germany
for a conference, and I saw
this arcade machine just kind
of hanging out on the corner.
And I was like, what is that?
Turns out the Instruct
folks were there too.
And they had one
of these machines,
and said they had some
developer challenges there.
And we just had so much time,
like a bunch of people crowded
around this little
arcade machine,
and we tried to outdo each
other to run a HTTP server, just
code golfing away, like the
fastest way we could do it,
and getting the highest scores.
And I was like,
this is so much fun.
We need one of
these at GCP Next.
So then got in contact
with the Instruct folks,
and we worked together to
actually bring some Google
Cloud games to Google
Cloud Next on the Instruct
platform running all
these arcade machines.
That's not a mouthful.
You tell me.
But basically, we take
the Instruct platform,
and Adé and team have put
it on these arcade machines,
and gamified it maybe with this
'80s or retro kind of theme.
And then my team, we took a
bunch of games based on GCP,
so Cloud Functions, BigQuery,
all these GCP technologies,
and then ported them to
the Instruct platform
so then attendees could
play them on the show floor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Which was a lot of fun,
and I think that we saw a
tremendous amount of people
at Next kind of hanging
around those arcade machines.
Just like you said, I want to
get back to how they were set
up at Next, but I guess,
Adé, the question is,
who thought of the
arcade machines?
How did that come about?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, yeah.
So that was actually
one of our developers
that had some sort of a
brainwave where we thought,
hey, we need to do something
different at conferences.
You can quite easily get
a booth, and get a stand,
and hang out, and give
people stickers or something.
But we thought, let's
do something different.
Let's bring an arcade
machine to a conference.
And then we got
started thinking,
so what do we need to
do to get this working,
get some traction?
We have a house designer.
We pitched the idea to him.
He basically said,
this is a great idea.
I'm going to build
a machine for you.
It's a custom build, so I'll
build the physical thing,
and you guys have to build
the software around it.
That's exactly what we did.
And we brought it to a
different conference,
and basically we put it there,
and the attraction was amazing.
So everybody wants to see
what this thing is about.
Basically, our
target audience, they
grew up in the '70s
and '80s, right?
And everybody knows
arcade machines.
Everybody has
played arcade games,
and everybody loves them.
So the moment people
see an arcade machine,
they're instantly drawn to it.
But then you walk up to
it, and you say, hey,
there's something different
about this arcade cabinet.
This one has a keyboard.
So what's going on?
Now people approach
it, they push start,
and they see this
different kind of content--
more serious games,
but still games.
People just love that.
JON FOUST: I definitely did.
I actually had access to the
showcase floor prior to Next,
and the first thing I saw
when I came down the escalator
was those arcade machines.
And I definitely walked
up, that's where I met Adé
for the first time, and I just
hung around for maybe two hours
or so.
And just to let you know,
guys, I am that game guy,
so you guys definitely caught
my attention immediately as soon
as I showed up.
But my question
is, although you've
been enticing a lot of people by
creating these arcade machines
and drawing them
in, can you tell us
almost like the motivation as
to why you use the machines?
I know that we wanted
to entice people,
we wanted to add a keyboard.
But what really draws
people to continue
to keep playing that games
once they get on the keyboard?
Because it is a
different type of game.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, it is
a different type of game.
But we do use gamification
elements like a leaderboard,
like different challenges,
like a validation step
where you actually get to
see whether what you're doing
is correct.
And all those elements,
they make people come back
to the arcade games, try to
beat their own high scores,
try to top the leaderboard.
So those are all elements
that really draw people
to these machines.
SANDEEP DINESH: Something
I can to add to that.
At Next one of the
really cool things that
happened was people came
back multiple times to try
to beat each other's
scores, and kept, like,
I can get higher than you.
And so the leaderboards
just kept going up and up,
and people were really
excited about that.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
So can you tell us
a little bit more
about why you decided to gamify
things, like learning by doing,
I guess, would be like the
best definition for it.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: So the idea
originated in a conference that
we got organized
together with HashiCorp.
So they organized the first
EU conference in Amsterdam,
and we were co-organizing.
And we thought, hey, let's
do something different.
We need to get the
tools of HashiCorp
into the hands of their users.
So we created a little bit
of a competition platform,
very similar to
what you currently
see on the arcade machines,
or on Instruct.com,
but we gave them
sandbox environments
with some challenges
around their form,
console, [INAUDIBLE].
And we asked them to solve it.
Purely to focus was a
competition platform.
And it was such a big
success that people even
went back to their
hotel because there
was better Wi-Fi to actually
solve the challenges.
But a lot of the
feedback that we also got
is this is a great way
to learn new technology.
Because a lot of
people, they maybe
touched one of these
tools, but not all four.
And we got people into
contact with different tools
that they never knew about, and
they learned a lot about it.
So that feedback
got us thinking.
So this is maybe a very good
way to learn new technology,
and make it into a learning
platform rather than just
a competition platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So on one side,
you've got the
arcade machines now,
which it sounds like
are pretty popular way.
Right?
I mean, any arcade machine
that doesn't require quarters,
I think, will get a pretty
big audience just by itself.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: [CHUCKLES] Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But you've also
combined it with
these online labs
and these different experiences.
How does the platform
where you actually setup
those labs-- how is
that actually built?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: So we build
on top of Kubernetes.
We use a lot of goaling
in our back end,
we use React for the front end,
and we use a lot of Terraform
to basically make
the platform happen.
That, in combination
with some Bash here
and there, maybe a
little bit too much,
but that's how the
internet runs, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, Bash
is the glue of the internet.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
JON FOUST: Don't bash on Bash.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: No, I
seriously love Bash.
If it weren't for Bash, I
would be lost, probably.
But as we're still a small
team, we're currently
with five people, we try to
use as many managed services as
possible.
So for Kubernetes, we use GKE.
For our database we
use Cloud Sequel.
For our build environments,
we use Cloud Build.
For authentication,
Firebase authentication.
So as many managed
services as possible,
so we can focus on things that
are important for us, as how
to spin up the sandboxes, how
to present it to the users,
all stuff like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's
not the first time
that we've kind of
seen a company try
to teach all the
technologies, and they
found that the best way
to teach it is also to run
on those same technologies.
So it's always super
interesting to hear about.
Yeah, you know, I
mean, what's the best
way to teach Kubernetes is
to get the managed Kubernetes
environment, and then you
run your info on there too.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
I think if you want
to start teaching,
you have to learn first.
So you have to learn
about this technology.
And once you get a little
bit of a grip on it,
then you can start
teaching other people.
Then you really start to
learn about this technology.
The best way to
learn, in my opinion,
is to teach others,
because you have
to go into a much
greater level of detail
to understand what
you're actually
doing to be able to explain
it to different people.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So Sandeep, how did that
translate into the work
that you kind of led, and
some of the other developer
advocates here, and developer
program engineers worked on?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah,
so the challenge
that we faced was how
to make traditionally,
quote unquote, "boring,
enterprise platform"
fun and exciting.
And so Instruct kind of helps
with that by having these,
like, checks as Adé calls them.
So every step of the way,
the platform actually
runs code on their side to check
that you actually completed
whatever task was set for you.
Right?
So you can't just cheat
your way through the games.
So that was really
powerful, being
able to run code to check
what they did, spinning up
their own sandbox, to
have an experiment,
and have a no guide rails.
Right?
So with that, with things
like our GKE challenge,
they could either
use a Kubernetes CLI,
they could write
it in a YAML file--
the choice was theirs on
how to solve these problems.
So that gave us as a
team a lot of flexibility
in designing them.
Right?
We didn't have to be
like kind of forced
into any sort of pattern.
As long as it worked
on the command line,
we could use it on
the Instruct platform.
And I found that
really powerful.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
stuff that you can do.
We also have an option
to run UIs, and maybe not
as effectively on
the arcade machines,
but our normal platform
does UIs, as well.
It allows us to expose
basically any web app or even
desktop sessions to users,
which makes it really powerful.
SANDEEP DINESH: So we actually
used Instruct's ability
to run arbitrary apps and
connect them to their back end
to run a full RPG in the
Instruct arcade machine.
So it was almost like
there was an actual video
game running in the arcade
machines that taught you
about coding.
It was "Inception"
in many levels.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: First
we're teaching people
about the environment running
on that actual environment.
Now we're basically just
modeling being real life.
[CHUCKLES]
JON FOUST: This is kind
of a funny question.
Maybe Adé would answer this.
So if I were at your arcade
machine and I just do up,
up, down, down, left,
right, left, right,
B, A, what would happen?
[CHUCKLES]
ADÉ MOCHTAR:
Unfortunately, nothing.
No.
[LAUGHING]
It is something that
we thought about.
I remember back-- I think it
was eight or nine years ago
at my previous company, we did
have that code on our website.
It would start showing My Little
Pony figures on the websites.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, I remember
that JavaScript library.
That was a fun one to add.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
JON FOUST: We've talked
about the platform,
and how it's built, and all
the technologies around it,
but I'm curious, what other
technologies do you actually
support in these sandboxes?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: So we support
with quite a wide range
of technology.
So in the basis we
can run containers
and virtual machines.
But we also have the ability to
start complete new Google Cloud
projects, or an AWS account.
And we're also looking at
adding different cloud vendors,
as well, and we
can mix and match
all these different
technologies.
So that gives you a lot of
freedom, a lot of flexibility
to create arbitrarily
complex environments
to basically create an
environment to teach
your users whatever you need.
JON FOUST: And, I'm curious,
when you're actually
working in technologies
in the sandboxes,
how do you actually
create these sandboxes,
and what kind of
challenges do you actually
have when you're creating them?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: So the definition
of the sandbox is it's just
a simple YAML file
that we defined.
So there you can
specify your containers
or your virtual
machines or whatnot.
And you can use standard
images from the Docker hub,
for instance, or from Google
Cloud's computer images.
And then we have
a set of scripts
that we can run on these
containers or virtual machines.
Those are simple Bash
scripts, and they
get executed on that
infrastructure in that sandbox
that you defined.
So you can basically do
arbitrary complex setups,
or simulations, or
whatever you need to do,
maybe break a cluster
and ask people to fix it.
That's all possible.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Was there anything
that you tried to set up,
either through the more
traditional classroom approach,
or maybe through the arcade
machines that just
didn't quite land right?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: The toughest thing
that we always have to do is
the more enterprise software,
because that tends to be slow
to start and difficult to
configure automatically.
But I don't think there's
anything that we encountered
that we could not do.
Eventually, with a lot of
hacking, a lot of testing,
and trial and error, we
usually get stuff running.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That,
and more Bash, right?
[LAUGHING]
[APPLAUSE]
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what's
next for the arcade machines?
I mean, they're already
obviously a pretty big hit,
but where are they
going to go next?
SANDEEP DINESH:
GopherCon next week,
which I don't know when
this podcast is coming out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, if you're
listening to this before then,
make sure you go.
If you're listening after, make
sure to check out the website.
And if you're listening
while it's going on,
just fly right out there.
[JET FLYING]
JON FOUST: Mark, not all of us
have private jets, you know?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah.
We're working on that, right?
But we also got--
well, currently,
we have the seven
arcade machines
at Google in the States, right?
But there's going to be more
arcade machines in Europe,
and then in Asia, as well.
So maybe you can tell a little
bit more about that, Sandeep?
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, so we're trying
to get arcade machines in
many of the Cloud Summits
around the world.
If you're in one of
those cities and you're
planning on attending
a Google Cloud Summit,
keep your eye out for
an arcade machine.
Other open source conferences
and stuff that we sponsor,
we're trying to get these into
the hands of as many people as
possible.
So yeah, keep your
eye out no matter
where you are in the world.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And I
assume the next iteration
is going to involve VR, right?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: That
would be so awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean, as
a kid playing arcade machines,
I know that stepping into that
world would be super cool.
You know, I mean,
there's nothing
quite like blasting aliens
but from a first person
perspective.
[SHOTS FIRING]
[ALIEN NOISES]
So now we just need
to be able to spin up
Kubernetes clusters from a
first person perspective.
ADÉ MOCHTAR: Yeah, that
puts a whole new dimension
to [INAUDIBLE], right?
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
Well, thank you all so much
for coming in and telling us
a little bit about it.
We're almost out of time here.
Is there anything you want to
call out or talk a bit more
about before we wrap up?
ADÉ MOCHTAR: So we do
have an open platform.
Anyone can start
playing for free,
start learning for
free at Instruct.com.
And we even have an option
to create content yourself.
So just reach out to us
at hello@instruct.com,
and we'll get you started
creating some cool content.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Well, Adé, thanks so much for
talking about all the cool
things Instruct does.
And Sandeep, I mean, great
job on leading that effort.
I think a lot of people got
some really, really cool hands
on experience at
Google Cloud Next,
and hopefully people
who can make it out
to GopherCon and
other conferences
worldwide will be able to
kind of get their hands
on these arcade machines.
SANDEEP DINESH: Very
cool, thank you.
JON FOUST: Definitely.
All right, Mark.
So our question of the week is--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--I want to be more
familiar with Google Cloud.
How do I navigate the
space for the material?
So what do you got for us?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
there's a lot of space here.
And I think that there's been
quite a few people who I've
heard, they see this different
information on Twitter,
on social posts, and I'm
sure it's a little confusing.
So let me give you
a quick rundown.
I would say the number
one thing right now
is that there is a certification
challenge going on.
And this certification
challenge is basically
you committing to saying,
I'm going to teach myself
this stuff in three
months, and then
if I get certified
within this three months,
either with the cloud
architecture or the data
engineer certification, you
get $100 for Google merch.
That's pretty cool, not to
mention the certifications come
with some swag of their own
like a backpack or a hoodie.
So you kind of have that power.
But you're probably in it
for more than just the swag.
You're hopefully also wanting
to learn about the Cloud.
So there's a mix of
different environments
in Qwiklabs and Coursera.
Qwiklabs are a great
place to start.
They'll organize
things in quests,
and these are all interactive
labs that you spin up,
you can work with directly, they
create a sandbox environment
for you, and then when the
lab is done you shut it down.
So these are very hands
on, very simple ways
to actually get through
some of these skills,
and practice what
they look like.
On the Coursera side, they're
a little bit more organized
in terms of there's videos,
there's text content,
and then there's some
hands on labs, as well.
But that has a much longer
breadth of detail you go into.
So with the Google Cloud
certification challenge,
each path has a list
of recommended Qwiklabs
and Coursera courses that
you can go through, feel
comfortable, set up a schedule
for a three month process
where you're taking these
things, you're training,
and of course, you're
practicing, and then at the end
you take that certification.
And if it all passes, you
get that $100 to spend.
So to kind of summarize
for getting started,
I'd recommend taking the
certification challenge,
looking at the Qwiklabs and
Coursera recommended courses
and labs respectively,
and then figuring out,
how can I make the time for
this over the next three months
to win that cool merch.
JON FOUST: That's
really awesome.
I am spending my time--
I'm taking it slowly
doing my certification,
but it's kind of
good to actually give
our developers who want to
get certified some incentive.
And trust me when I
tell you that some
of the merch that
people get when
they pass these certifications
are really awesome.
Like those blue puffer jackets
that they were walking around
with Next were pretty,
pretty awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
it was super cool to see.
And I think people
were excited to see
all the different
available things.
I think at Next they were even
giving out like little metals
that you could hang
around your neck
if you had gotten
certified there.
JON FOUST: Yeah, right.
If it were up to
me, what I would get
is just continuing to buy
multiple Android figurines.
I love collecting those things.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, there's
so many out there now.
You now what we need is
we need a Cloud figurine.
JON FOUST: I think we
have one, actually.
I'll send you a picture.
But I would really
like a new one.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Well, take this up to
marketing, and for anyone
who's listening to
this podcast, just
give us some time to
figure the details out.
JON FOUST: Oh, they should do a
contest, like design your own.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
you need to start it
with designing the first one.
Then we can get them
to design their own.
JON FOUST: Right.
Right, right, right.
[CHUCKLES] So Mark, where
are you going to be?
Where are you traveling to next?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, yeah.
I've got a fun little few
days in the east coast.
So I'm going to fly across,
and hopefully the heat wave
breaks by then.
We'll have to see.
And then I'll be
flying out to Austin,
where I think it is
perpetually pretty warm,
to talk to some customers there,
and hopefully get a fun podcast
or video recording out of it.
How about yourself?
JON FOUST: I will be speaking
at PAX Dev in August, which
is pretty awesome.
And I get to attend
PAX West, as well.
So I'll be there in Seattle end
of August going into September.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
What's your talk on at PAX Dev?
JON FOUST: My talk is on
universal communication
and its benefits in games.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Give
us a sneak preview.
JON FOUST: A lot of people
quit games based on the fact
that sometimes there's a
language barrier, especially
people who are in countries
that are not their own,
and they're trying
to play games.
So instead of waiting multiple
hours for their servers
to be live, or just
not talking, creating
some type of universal
communication
where they can communicate
with their team,
and speak comfortably
in their own language
would be kind of awesome.
So I'm going to
explore that space,
and show how it may benefit
games, especially when you
have multi-regional games.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Super cool.
So remember, people, if
you're going to be at PAX Dev,
check out that talk.
And I'm sure there's going to
be lots of other talks, as well.
Probably tons of
great content there.
JON FOUST: Should be fun.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
JON FOUST: So thank
you all for listening,
and we hope to all
see you next week.
Have fun, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We'll see ya.
[AMBIENT MUSIC]
SANDEEP DINESH:
Turning up the volume.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What you're saying is,
Sandeep, you're
pumping up those jams.
[RECORD SCRATCHING]
SANDEEP DINESH:
Pump up the jams.
[RECORD SCRATCHING]